let g of x equal one over x can we use
the mean value theorem to say that the
equation g prime of x is equal to one
half has a solution where negative one
is less than x is less than two if so
write a justification all right pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out
so the key to using the mean value
theorem to even before you even think
about using it you have to make sure
that you are continuous over the closed
interval and differentiable over the
open interval so this is the open
interval here and then the closed
interval would include the endpoints
but you might immediately realize that
both of these intervals contain x equals
0 and at x equals 0 the function is
undefined and if it's undefined there
well it's not going to be continuous or
differentiable at that point and so no
not
continuous
or
differentiable
over
the interval
over the interval all right let's do the
second part can we use the mean value
theorem to say that there is a value c
such that g prime of c is equal to
negative one half and one is less than c
is less than two if so write a
justification so pause the video again
all right so in this situation between 1
and 2 on both the open and the closed
intervals well this is a rational
function and a rational function is
going to be continuous and
differentiable at every point in its
domain and its domain completely
contains this open and closed interval
or another way to think about it every
point on this open interval and on the
closed interval is in the domain
so we can write g of x
is a rational
function which lets us know that it is
continuous
and differentiable
at every point in this domain
at every
point
in
its domain
the closed interval from 1 to 2 is
in
domain
and so now let's see what the average
rate of change is from 1 to two
and so we get g of two minus g of one
over two minus one is equal to one half
minus one over one which is equal to
negative one half
therefore
by
the
mean value theorem
there must
be
a c
where
one is less than c is less than two and
g prime of c
is equal to the average rate of change
between the endpoints
negative
one half and we're done so we could put
a big yes right over there and then this
is our justification